Good Morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's question Tuesday, the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters, let's get right to it!
What's your least favorite kind of animal?
Mice who lord over theme parks.
What's your favorite dance move?
This one. You take this guys up and then OH, you're dancing.
I'm dancing. <Hits printer with leg> OW.
I wanna apologise to my printer.
Why does everyone like ferrets so much?
I don't know who you're hanging out with, but that is not an issue in my house.
What's your favorite photograph?
This one, called "Young farmers", also sometimes known as "Three farmers on their way to a dance, August 1914".
There were two dances that they were on their way to, of course, the one they knew about and
World War I. How's Willy?
He's good. Here, you can watch him for the next several questions.
TFiOS casting?! Yes, Ansel Elgort has been cast as Augustus Waters and Hazel Grace Lancaster will be
played by Shailene Woodley.
But I am a GIANT SQUID OF ANGER about this!! Yeah, that's not a question but I am grateful that you are
passionate about the book and want it to be a good movie but you have to understand-
I ALSO want it to be a good movie and I've actually seen the auditions and you aren't going to
think "Oh, that's Shailene Woodley" or "Oh, that's the guy who plays Caleb Prior in Divergent",
you're just gonna think "Oh, that's Hazel and Gus".
How much say do you actually have in casting?
A surprising amount. I mean, I'm definitely not casting the movie but the producers and the director
have been really really nice about including me in everything!
What did you think of the Gatsby movie? <frustrated sigh>
Hey, what would you do if you were invisible for an hour?
I would go to the emergency room. I mean, I'm pretty hypochondriacal but I assume that anyone who
suddenly became invisible would proceed with some haste to the nearest healthcare provider and be like,
"Why am I invisible?! I Googled it but there is nothing in the medical literature. Perhaps we should do a CAT scan!"
How many times a day do you check your cellphone?
I'm sorry, what's that?
Are you good at multitasking?
Studies consistently show that the better people think they are at multitasking, the worse they actually are and
I am GREAT at it.
How does it feel to be a doctor?
About the same as it felt before, actually.
Did they let you keep your cape thing?
DID they? I've hardly taken it off. By the way, it is technically known as a cape thing.
Would you rather fight a rabid badger or Nicholas Cage?
Well, I'm gonna have to know more about the badger - is it a regular badger or a honey badger?
Is it like a baby badger? If it's a regular baby badger, I'm gonna take the rabid badger. Otherwise,
definitely Nick Cage.
If you could only recommend one book to nerdfighteria, what would it be?
Well, that changes weekly. At the moment, my recommendation for zombie novels is "The End Games" but T. Michel Martin, for non-zombie
novels, I'm gonna recommend "How To Get Filthy Rich In Rising Asia"
If I were to gift you a pegasus, what color would you like it to be?
Listen, that's very nice of you but I do not want a pegasus. First, there's the fact that I don't have
a barn in which to house a pegasus. Also, there's the not insignificant cost of hay.
Plus, I've always found flying pets to be kind of more trouble than they're worth.
Hey, where do the ducks go when the pond freezes over?
They migrate South. EXCEPT in the actual case of Holden Caulfield, wondering what happens
to the ducks in the central park pond. They do not migrate South because the pond never freezes over.
As the official photographer for central park put it "I don't know what Salinger was thinking. I've worked at the park
for 27 years and I've always seen ducks in the winter."
Have you ever been tempted to get nerdfighters to tame honey badgers so you could have a Broadway musical
starring honey badgers? Yeah, I can see the headline now "Man convinces children to tame honey
badgers for strange Broadway musical. 7 dead, including no honey badgers."
Hank, D.F.T.B.A, I will see you on Friday.